well with just three days before this
big election uh MSNBC which as I always
tell people if you watch it knowing that
it's a televised mental institution it's
much more entertaining uh they're trying
to freak people out to the highest level
I mean this one was truly this is truly
truly bananas here's a presidential
historian on uh what's about to happen
this speech seemed in some senses more
specific about the developments that
we're seeing everywhere from the Arizona
poll stalkers to the Secretary of State
who who refuse to uh say that they'll
accept the elections what do you view as
the key takeaway of the speech tonight
we could be six days away from losing
our rule of law and losing a situation
where we have elections that we all can
rely on a historian will say what was at
stake tonight and this week was the fact
whether we will be a democracy in the
future whether our children will be
arrested and conceivably killed we're on
the edge of a brutal authoritarian
system and it could be a week away
Viva we're not only losing democracy uh
but they're also going to kill the
children I mean but what is going on
here I should have been wearing the
shirt that says confession through
projection because the only P the only
party that's been jailing people I'll
save I'll save the I'll I'll not get
into the killing of people but jailing
people
bastardizing democracy has been the the
party in power for the last two years
jailing Bannon jailing all of their
political adversaries acquitting all of
their you know political allies this man
is describing what the party that is
trying to preserve its control is and
has been doing it's confession through
projection through and through but my
goodness that's hyperbolic even for that
individual who I've never heard of
before
malice I take it that you'd be okay with
some kidnapping and killing of children
in the name of Liberty well only the fat
and ugly ones but I I do want to point
out that some of us do grow up that have
normal happy lives please and then but
Viva I just want to make your point you
just made my argument for me the
Democrats are imprisoning their
political opponents and and you get to
sit here and kind of roll your eyes and
laugh about it which of those two sides
is winning the people laughing or the
people doing the imprisoning which side
would you want to be on I I I'll if
malice you might call me the person who
would rather die than kill but I would
rather not be the people doing the evil
so uh in as much as I I think
repercussions for those who do I I would
not want to be that monster I wouldn't I
wouldn't feel better living with myself
like that than living as a victim of of
that type of violence okay and that is
exactly why America is in the state it's
in today because of people like you on
the right
I'm Canadian dude
well he also wisely moved to Florida
where we have some defenses against
against some of this stuff and by the
way Florida malice is doing some of the
things that you were asking some of the
states to do related to voting we are
encouraging uh in-person voting you have
to have an ID they're discouraging
mail-in ballots although they're doing a
little bit because of the hurricane so
there are it's a little easier I think
maybe for Viva to say it here in the
safety of Florida because it's true
rather than in Canada